>> SOMETIMES IN LIFE WHAT IS
IMPORTANT IS WHAT ISN'T SAID IS
WHAT IS SAID.
THE COMPLAINTS ABOUT THE GOP
ESTABLISHMENT BEING OVERBLOWN,
27 HOURS AFTER WE FIRST LEARNED
ABOUT THE FBI RAID OF THE HOME
OF PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE TOP
REPUBLICAN LEADERS IN THE
SENATE, THEY STILL KIND OF SEEM
UNSURE HOW TO REACT.
THE SENATE MINORITY LEADERS
SEEMED BOTHERED NOT BY THE RAID
BUT THE QUESTION OF THE RAID.
>> I'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE
FLOOD AND TO RECOVER FROM THE
FLOOD.
>> THEN AT 7:00 P.M., 24 HOURS
AFTER THIS, AND A BARRAGE OF
COMPLAINTS FROM THE CONSERVATIVE
BASE, MCCONNELL FINALLY OFFERED
THE BARE MINIMUM OF WHAT
SHOULD'VE BEEN SAID ALL ALONG.
>> IT ALREADY SHOULD HAVE
PROVIDED ANSWERS TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND MUST DO SO
IMMEDIATELY.
JOHN THUNE SAID HE WAS TALKING
ABOUT WHAT WAS HAPPENING.
THE SENATE GOP HAD A MILD
OBSERVATION SAYING IT'S
UNPRECEDENTED AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT NEED TO QUICKLY AND
TRANSIENTLY TELL THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND IF THEY BELIEVE THAT
THIS NEWLY MILD RESPONSE IS A
WAY TO KEEP OUR AND WIN BACK
POWER, THEY ARE SOLELY COULD NOT
WAIT FOR THEM TO HAVE HIS COME
OFFICE.
AND THEY REALIZE IF THEY DON'T
STAND UP FOR THEM NOW, THIS IS
NOT STANDING UP FOR THE MIDDLE
CLASS.
AND REMEMBER, THESE SAME
GENIUSES OF LEGISLATIVE
MANEUVERING ARE FRESH OFF OF A
MASSIVE LEGISLATIVE SCREWUP ON
THE TAX AND IRS AND CLIMATE
CHANGE BILL.
THEY GAVE THE DEMOCRATS A PASS
TO THE BIG WIN BY VOTING FOR THE
$1.2 TRILLION SO-CALLED
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL EARLIER THIS
YEAR.
>> MY GOODNESS, WHY WOULDN'T YOU
WANT IN THIS.
WE MET WHY NOT DO WHAT NANCY
PELOSI DID AND SAID SHOW US YOUR
HAND FIRST, LET'S SEE THE FULL
TEXT OF THE RECONCILIATION BILL
AND TAX INCREASES, ALL OF THE
NIGHTMARES THAT WE ALREADY
DELINEATED.
LET THEM SHOW THEIR HAND AND YOU
GUYS GOT PLAYED ON THIS.
YOU HAD TO VOTE FIRST OR AGREE
FIRST.
THEY STILL HAD NOT SHOWN THE
TEXT OF THEIR LEGISLATION.
>> THE IRONIC THING IS THAT YOU
ARE AGREEING WITH THIS, WITH
PELOSI.
>> COMING BACK ON THE SHOW, WHAT
DO YOU SAY, WRONG OR RIGHT?
>> WELL, IT SOMEHOW STILL HAPPEN
WITH SOMEONE TO BLAME.
LOOK AT THE LOGIC IF YOU KNOW
THAT.
Laura: MAYBE NOT THE
3.5 TRILLION.
>> THESE FOOLS GAVE
HIM A BIPARTISAN VICTORY ANOTHER
DEMOCRATS WILL UNLEASH AN ARMY
OF AGENTS AGAINST CONSERVATIVE
AMERICANS FROM EVERY CORNER OF
THE COUNTRY.
THESE REPUBLICANS, AND THEY
DON'T HAVE THE DECENCY TO STATE
THE OBVIOUS REMARK AND THE JOE
BIDEN PEOPLE ARE EXACTING
REVENGE.
BUT BECAUSE THEY ARE AFRAID THAT
IF HE WINS IN 2024 HE WILL
FINALLY JOIN THE SWAMP THAT THE
BIPARTISAN CABAL HAS BEEN